[Musique]
tous
on le sait
ce soit
j'espère
mais que faire
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais que fait de trop
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors ouais j'ai été devant bfm tv la
juge alors bayat a vu le scoop là c'est
incroyable coelho non il fait froid
l'hiver
tiens au courant il fait froid l'hiver
la neige regardez toute l'année bfm pas
il fait froid il fêtera à ils sont en
boucle jour et nuit c'est fou d'ailleurs
1 2 - 3 j'ai suivi ça [ __ ] ça me
rappel en septembre j'étais
[Applaudissements]
et pour pas qu'on se fasse baiser
l'année prochaine
ça nous serve de leçon cette d'histoire
géo
[Musique]
jobs
ok
ça fait je me réveille la tête quand je
suis parti en bambou régulière
pourrait dire je vais la tête dans moi
je suis pas fier
ababou réduire j'ai besoin d'amour de
ranger
dans la vie pour tout changer
dans la vie pour tout changer talât du
pour tout changer
de changer
matin pour le ranger aura 10 pour tout
changer d'âme à temps pour me ranger
l'adie pour tout changer pour adam
satire dans les handicaps et afrique
allume son cerveau crs comme ma jeep qui
s'est tapé ses rêves communs voire
l'usure booska p hro tu devrais faire
les comptes de ta vie ça dépasse tapant
dans les poches de tara veste et on a
combien qui même si je mens pas aller
oui gros finale mais moi je déteste
libye non j'arrête c'est pour samir j'ai
raison chez georges blanc du jeu me dira
des fois je me sankara map est renfermé
qui rêve de prendre son enfant dans ses
bras comme un cas social qui sera du
foyer comme une allocation à son loyer
juste comme une famille nombreuse qu'on
ait vu ce que tout le monde regarde en
train de se noyer et tout le monde le
crime et toi tu entends pas tam négliger
les rend pas y avait pas de photo
pendant le délibéré hier d'hectares mais
qui faisait les cent pas tu as toi qui
étais sous tasse à péter frey et puis tu
as perdu ta blonde tu t'es senti seul
évincé da lunaire par le plus gros
nuages du monde je
reviens encore mourir
encore bourreaux d'hier je me réveille
la tête en bois je suis pas bien en
bambou retient j'ai besoin tabata pour
de manger
pour tout changer
tout changer dans la vie pour tout
changer
amy pour tout changer
à temps pour le rangement
l'adie pour de changer la main
raté pour tout changer j'ai besoin de
toi pour me sortir de là sous-estimée
comme un billet froissant besoin de toi
pour me sortir de là
j'me suis coincé monde a dit est passé
il suffira dans la vie je me réveille la
tête en bois je suis pas fier
alors pour réduire
jme révélateur dans son jeu
j'ai besoin d'en matin pour le venger
arrivé tout changer
du pur tout changer
as-tu pour tout changer
brad pour le ranger
est ce qu'il ya quelqu'un ici
[Musique]
du saumon dassault
social le morceau s'appelle
et l'album sa femme affranchie il sera
le 9 décembre
oser me tue a reconnu ou quoi j'espère
que c'est pas l'enculé qui a bloqué
l'autoroute parce que déjà xi déjà que
ça roule mal
[Applaudissements]
canwest
de la lumière à l'ombre on est en bas
tall un équipage comme des gants noirs
schématique pailleté boudard medellin
c'est magique c'est pas moi qui tanger
med gym qui ma chute je te reconnais
plus je ne reconnaîtrai ça va ça vient
ça repart dans une fois ci
il a pris et a pris 4 1 avec sursis et
1500 euros d'amendé trois mois au péage
il était venu ici déjà ils avaient
envahi plateau tu te souviens pas
dechavanne était très inquiet regarde
[Musique]
y'a aucune sécurité aujourd'hui
c'est nous la sécu ça fait peur quand
ils se regroupent quand même
tu dis des trucs sont alors bien sûr
parce que tes potes tuft hagen c'est ça
c'est ça et on est plein ouais j'ai vu
la ramène pas trop laurent caure n'ai
pas peur c'est pas encore ça comme un
tapissage way pour moi c'est le 4 genre
connaît formellement le cas
et
m
et le sex pistols c'est pour paul taylor
bonsoir
tanguay documalis vous êtes sur la scène
de la nouvelle eve tous les jeudis
vendredis samedis à 20h avec votre
spectacle qui s'appelle hashtag
franglais c'est un one man show moitié
en anglais mathieu en français où vous
raconter votre vie d'anglais à paris en
jouant sur les clichés sur les
différences la bise ouais ça vous choque
ouais c'est ça ma choquer au début parce
que je connaissais pas le système et je
connais toujours pas le système et de ce
que j'ai découvert les français
connaissent pas le système non plus on
ne sait pas combien cancale côté du
visage comme fer ouais mais ça dépend
des régions et vous êtes mal à l'aise je
vous vois entre vous être un peu mal à
l'aise avec ça donc c'est un truc que
j'avais observé donc je ris de ça mais
maintenant que j'ai dans le showbiz la
bise il va falloir vous y faire c'est
tout le temps c'est le show de doc
gynéco et dans un premier temps
faire une bise à christine bah non c'est
en dégoûte montrer combien banque
signale des gouttes encore plus
dans votre spectacle vous parler mais si
des fonds de l'ami besoin d'un dressing
les français pensent que c'est un
endroit où les anglais range la leurs
vêtements alors que pour les anglais un
dressing c'est une sauce coincé c'est
vrai mais sur une salade c'est ça c'est
ça il y en a pas mal de d'anglicismes
faire d'effort et investissement le
cheminot king par exemple ça c'est
smoking pour nous c'est de ces quelques
idiots fume tel fils au nom de l'état
ctie donc je sais pas pourquoi on a pas
pourquoi on a dû s'incliner en france je
sais pas dans votre spectacle est là
dessus donc on regarde à quoi ça
ressemble
[Musique]
aux élèves pour voir paul taylor ça va
parler miang lemmy français on est là
pour parler franglais je vais changer au
fur et à mesure du spectacle de l'eau de
langue donc si vous n'êtes pas
confortable avec sa gouaille et qu'une
fois encore par cartes de noël fearon
essaye de le jouer comme as si un truc
qu'il faut pas taper dans google c'est
les deux jours ensemble hamas c'est pas
du verlan
voilà tu vas malange etsaut suite au
caire
le mec devant moi il a fait plein
voilà je passe pour un débile à chaque
fois je suis fan du sirha women of the
french palestine readiness nabli oui je
t'emmerde un peu cheap il s'en est vu
c'est pas beau ça c'est des bruits et
des sons qui sortent se veut à paul
arrêtent de chercher midi à quatorze
heures plus tard excuse me du bnic and
speak english
speaking fromagerie secret story
5 qui savent assumer une fantastique
train qui gagnent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si vous parlez si bien le français c'est
parce que vous l'avez appris très jeune
en fait vous êtes né le 11 octobre 1986
à l'ombre père anglais mr irlandais the
voice yes thierry i'm sorry but i'm not
claverie nar tout comme m in english
faible en français on traduira je pense
que je peux faire
dont le père anglais mère irlandaise
vous grandissez d'abord à genève puis en
france j'avais 9 ans quand vos parents
divorcent et vous repartez ans à londres
mais le français vous manque et vous
décidez de l'étudier à l'université
jusqu'à ce que vous rencontriez une
française adeline qui deviendra votre
épouse c'est ça ou la fatigue et pas
trop et vos conneries mais
beaucoup
qui prend qui prend toutes les blagues
en premier et surtout si une grande
inspiration parce que souvent les
malentendus et c'est entre moi et elle
en fait les faits commencent que ses
seins puis un jour j'ai 22 ans le destin
[Musique]
on
assister pour la première fois un
spectacle de stand-up à la fac et là
c'est la révélation vous dit c'est ça
que je veux faire en fait c'est ça il y
avait il y avait un spectacle de
stand-up à l'université est en fait
j'avais deux ou trois personnes qui
savent si c'est pas ça rigolait pas en
fait et je moi j'avais du mal à
comprendre comment il s'était payé pour
pas faire rire et je me suis dit ça doit
être pas si compliqué que ça donc jamais
tuer c'est après j'ai appris très vite
que j'ai fait des scènes ouvertes et
saab idée totalement et gpa d'accord
c'est c'est plus compliqué que prévu là
vous essayez scène ouverte à l'ombre
ouais ça doit être dur ça non des parle
mal le la culture anglaise dans les
clubs de comédie c'est très on s'assoit
et on a le droit de gueuler quand on
veut si si au bout de 30 secondes c'est
pas marrant on peut dire fuck off ce cas
là c'est dommage c'est pareil en france
j'ai des mecs qu'on traîne depuis 30 ans
qu'ils sont nuls par exemple
alors 2009 vous apprenez que votre
employeur steve jobs ouvre des magasins
en france dont vous revenez en france
avec adeline hélas il perdure c'est
crevant de votre vie un peu comme les
produits que vous vendez votre batterie
se décharge très très vite dans la
fournaise est fatigué
mais le stand-up nous trotte toujours
dans la tête et en 2015 décidé de vous
consacrer à la scène et à youtube
regarde
[Musique]
pour mars et où quoi les et gage du
siège qui me font du cap et a failli
[Musique]
au cinéma jean pierre meyer s'enraye
shopping bag faux noms
du cinéma et c'est
exactement
et part que moi et que je respecte une
excuse il faut savoir comment ils
nous sont précieuses je vais bien ne
t'en fais pas de battre mon coeur s'est
arrêté si tu marches je te tue un été
chez serge gainsbourg et jean pierre
fritsch poteau par attaquant du fc
twente de manchester non je sors
number of the box office it for you
bring on the road show comédie bienvenue
chez les ch'tis et de ce fait robin et
benoît que de west of england orgueil
signe fort au marqueur noir et ses six
matches cool hello my name is bonne dany
c'est franchement c'est très
bien
le cinéma français c'est un sujet
inépuisable toute façon alors maintenant
que vous êtes un vrai français est ce
que vous détestez les anglais comme nous
ben c'est pour ça que je suis venu à la
base parce que aussi je n'aime pas mon
propre pays les gens propres pays
j'habitais à londres avant donc c'est un
peu un peu insupportable comme toutes
les grandes villes il y avait trop de
monde en fait donc du coup je décide de
venir ici la bouffe et les meilleurs le
vent il est mieux tout à mieux
et maintenant on va faire une interview
englishman in paris sockeye aurait dit
fière d'eux
vous les français quand vous faites la
fête vous faites pas trop la fête chez
les gens parce que comme vous perdez
votre temps avec la bise une fête
anglaise si ça c'était une soirée en
angleterre moi je peux rentrer j'espère
que non ils stimulent collectivement
mais en france dont les soirées et pas
cette année ben c'est bonjour comment ça
va enchanter sait comment ça va faire
une demi heure
on
n'a pas le temps de faire la fête ou les
français donc fait l'amour quand vous
faites l'amour les français vous avez
des phrases bizarre il ya une phrase que
j'ai appris c'est bien sûr moi ouais moi
j'ai traduit ça comme j'étais en france
quand j'étais petit j'avais pas le
vocabulaire du sexe encore donc j'ai
traduit sa littéralement dans le grand
monde mais retraduit en français je vous
lis sur moi un relais français quand
vous parlez bah vous parlez vous
utilisez des anglicismes qui n'ont aucun
sens le footing c'était un autre qu'on
en parle et toi le footing boeuf footing
ce alors que le footing en fait c'est
vachement porno sur une croissance
propres du monde a dit on veut ses
footings s'appelle mandiang les running
on dit jogging à joggi mais jogging en
france si le pantalon mais pour aller
faire du footing donc la logique que je
sais
alors vous le français quand vous parler
une langue étrangère quand vous parlez
des langues étrangères non
[Applaudissements]
voulu penser que vous êtes malade les
français quand vous êtes malade vous
aimez bien inséré des choses dans vos
culs
les sacs en toile les super me regarde
pas quand tu es déjà quand tu ne connais
pas ma vie quand il faudrait une
suppositoire et suppositoires les
médicaments c'est la bouche les
thermomètres ça va dans le cul oui alors
que d'habitude on met dans la bouche le
terme elle en angleterre c'est en
dessous de la bouche mon ami m'a dit que
c'était pas prêt si la température si on
met ça dans la bouche c'était sale et
que tous les anglais les suppositoires
vous la météo
dans la bouche par accident
nous les français quand vous êtes jeunes
vous vous parlez en verlan les jeunes il
parle ah oui oui et c'est un concept que
je connaissais pas du tout d'inverser
les mots et tu comprendras non plus ou
moins il ya des phrases quand même qui
me perturbe mais il ya le double verlan
aussi à vapeur revu en baisse à
vous les pensez quand vous jurer
quand vous jurer en france vous aimez
bien encore une fois les culs et les
expressions de merde et à tout ce truc
de ça me fait chier est mike smith est
emmerdé envoyer chier se chier dessus
avoir plein de qu enfin
c'est une obsession
voilà j'ai tellement mal en france
les terriens
[Musique]
ap
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sur lui
scott
christine mois
camilla
caron
à vue
première terrienne invité ce soir elle
vient de fêter ses 30 ans de carrière on
va désormais l'appeler christine
bravissimo
[Musique]
premier carrière avis que ce soit acteur
réalisateur et désormais auteur clovis
cornillac nous parlera de son dernier
livre
autre carrière invité ce soir le seul
végétarien qui a bouffé du lion aymeric
caron
autres terriens invités ce soit le
comique anglais qu'on paye pour se
[ __ ] de notre gueule bolt est là
alex vizorek en p3 nous acquérons entre
terrienne du samedi soir le dernier
mythe grec nana mouskouri
émission s'appelle salut les terriens le
goût et gréement de fortune et leur
stade et m
[Applaudissements]
et la classe immense et camilla
[Musique]
à
ça va tu es tu perds notre premier
invité à des lunettes et on s'est
beaucoup moqué de lui à l'école à cause
de ses cheveux et de son accent
christine barrault bonsoir
racing a mis ses petites lunettes rouges
idiot comme quoi on dit beaucoup de bien
d'afflelou et la deuxième paire un euro
mais des fois sont pas terribles un
comme
ça c'était le vide greniers de jean
pierre coffe
beaucoup cas christine où venaient pour
la télé 2 bravo diffusée sur ces huit
voilà si ç'avait été sur nrj12 ça aurait
été la télé à bravo et c'est bien trente
ans de télé c'est sûr c'est vide voilà
quand c'est michel drucker c'est sur la
chaîne histoire et non à 30 ans derrière
ça quand on a un nom comme le veau de
bravo on était obligé d'avoir du succès
moi je m'appelle village en appart j'ai
l'air d'un con ça tout à l'heure il ya
nana mouskouri qui viendra mouskouri
resservir longévité en grec mais non je
déconne se dire plat à gratin et son
balai
christine bravo qui a présenté froufrous
c'était la première émission française
uniquement composée par des femmes celui
qui a eu l'idée vraiment je pas dit ça
mais il va avoir un talent
extraordinaire c'est qu'ils tuent elles
c'est vrai ouais c'est pas vous moi j'ai
fait que produire l'émission grand
témoin ah c'est vous qui produisit et ça
c'est malin ou non mais c'est très mal
là on sent le producteur parce que bon
vous avez passé pour un féminisme en
avant gardisme et surtout en les payant
moitié moins vous avez économisé
beaucoup d'argent pour son
épisode bon à part christine vous avez
tout pris des chemins différents depuis
fu fu tina kieffer par exemple sur les
devis pour se consacrer uniquement
maintenant à l'humanitaire sonia dubois
l'a perdu du poids elle est retombée
dans l'oubli joëlle goron est leur
maison de retraite aujourd'hui ea non
pardon aller sur rtl au tampon non mais
finalement il ya vous qui vous en sortez
bien ça c'est cool il paraît que sonia
dubois d'ailleurs est prête à reprendre
du poids et à manger du nutella pour
faire la télé avec vous c'est vrai
maintenant grâce à ses logiciels l'a dit
mais oui bien sûr comme quoi s'il
suffisait de bouffer du chocolat pour
refaire la télé philippe risoli on
l'appellerait kinder bueno tu vois ça
notre invité suivantes y est il est
comédien il a joué à un cycliste un
animateur radio un pilote d'avion de
chasse des flips des voyous même astérix
et le mec de virginie efira bref c'est
plus un cv c'est un rêve de gosse c'est
le must en bien
clovis cornillac qui vient pour belle et
sébastien 3 voilà il a fait toute la
promo sembel pourquoi il s'est fait
monter la tête par brigitte bardot du
coup elle a pris le melon est belle et
sébastien ça va cartonner les deux
premiers ont fait 5 millions et ça même
cartonné à l'international en italie
crois que ça fait un million et demi bon
sauf en chine évidemment où il n'aime
pas qu'on joue avec la nourriture
alors attention le film sur le jour de
la saint valentin voilà il faut bien
préciser si jamais vous allez le 14 avec
votre fan dit bien que c'est pour belle
et sébastien parce que si vous dites
chéri ce soir on va voir un film sur une
grosse chienne c'est pas très vendeur
en tout cas attirer notre troisième
invité sa fervent défenseur de la cause
animale comme pamela anderson mais en
beaucoup moins bonne c'est mme ricard
alors aimons et par an au début de votre
carrière vous avez couvert les conflits
au kosovo en irak en afghanistan en côte
d'ivoire et au congo vous avez eu
beaucoup de chance parce qu'aujourd'hui
vous pourriez être mariée à jean jacques
bourdin et c'est ce qu'ils pensaient
oui d'ailleurs je suis je suis choquée
qui n'ait pas été présenté comme grand
reporter et
journaliste écrivain voilà et c'est quoi
la fin 2014 vous avez annoncé
officiellement que vous étiez vegan mais
c'est que vous êtes un fervent défenseur
de la cause animale il va même très loin
aymeric jusqu'à défendre joe cocker
serge bernard lama yves et bernard lecoq
didier bourdon et jean michel jarre
c'est très très fort même si
les ricains qui sort un nouveau livre
qui s'appelle couteau pia 21 voilà et
pas utopia croit croit bâton quand
franck ribéry et
ses utopies à 21 c'est votre cinquième
livre pour un écolo à battre autant
d'armes pour mieux le télécharger vaut
mieux le télécharger mais ça doit être
probablement c'est un papier recyclé
c'est ça votre question je ferais
redemander moi je demande du papier
recyclé après mario j'en ai envie de
nager j'ai appelé l'éditeur et récupère
des vieux bouquins de finkielkraut qui
broie comme ça et ils plantent des
arbres sur les parkings de la fnac donc
tout va bien entre l'applaudir 4
et puis pour finir tirer notre dernier
invité contrairement à jane birkin et
nous fait croire qu'il a un accent
britannique c'est monsieur paul taylor
s'il vous plaît
alors paul cayla on vous l'avait dit
c'est l'anglais qui se moque des
français et ça q tu es beaucoup foutu de
notre gueule danté white the fuck france
entre moquant de la france de notre
administration notre fromage du vin
sérieusement paul je veux qu'on compare
nos pays
votre gâteau le plus connu c'est le
pudding on dirait du cac à votre boisson
c'est la bière on dirait du pipi le
matin vous manger des haricots à la
tomate sur du pain regardez la photo
c'est pas un menu on dirait une gastro
sans déconner est ce que tu veux qu'on
continue paul dans le vêtement le plus
célèbre de ton pays c'est le parapluie
je me ferais tout petit à ta place et
encore j'ai la délicatesse de ne pas
parler du physique des gens parce que tu
as vue légal les anglais on se croirait
dans le couloir des urgences c'est
dégueulasse vraiment et non mais
j'ai pas le temps j'ai pas le temps on
se mord les anglais ils sont débiles
vous avez six équipes de foot pour
représenter une seule ville londres vous
avez inventé le football et vous avez
payé coupe du monde depuis 1966 c'est
tellement vieux à l'époque les mecs qui
jouent avec des sabots et le ballon
c'était une pause de brebis gonflés en
plus aux a gagné au penalty contre
l'allemagne l'allemagne de l'ouest il y
avait que la moitié du pays et le et le
rugby le rugby on en parle ou par les
équipes les plus fortes au rugby c'est
la nouvelle-zélande l'australie
l'afrique du sud l'angleterre le pays de
galles l'irlande et l'écossé pas une
coupe du monde c'est une cour
britannique y'a que des colonies à vous
ou des membres du commonwealth c'est
comme si on vous avait pas une coupe du
monde de pétanque etc la côte d'azur la
provence et les corses bien que vous que
s'intéresse le rugby alors oui vous avez
les beatles d'accord mais chez nous les
beatles en france ils font la première
partie de sylvie vartan à l'olympia et
james bond aussi james bond c'est
tellement pas d'idée de film ça fait 55
ans vous faites le même ça et la reine
d'angleterre ça c'est génial vous êtes
fan d'une vieille qui fait la gueule et
vous faites des jours fériés pour un
mariage ou une naissance et tu oses
faire what the fuck france quoi tu fais
trois minutes nous on peut faire deux
jours par épisode alors calme-toi
et on passe maintenant à notre invité
polémique de la semaine
[Musique]
du vent
aymeric car en revanche soit
ramené à très bien bien enlevé récemment
déclaré j'ai été l'une des premières
personnes publiques en france a
revendiqué son végétarisme à l'époque
dire qu'on était végétarien était aussi
compliqué qu'à assumer son homosexualité
on s'est beaucoup foutu de moi sur les
plateaux télé aujourd'hui c'est fini je
sais pas j'attends de voir si dit
maintenant ce soit
beaucoup changé ici je vois oui au loto
il est végétarien
j'aimerais que ça
l'intéressé disons qu'ils ont beaucoup
changé depuis ce que j'ai à dire est
qu'elle voulait lapins ont commencé à
apprendre la confiance et des lapins qui
s'attaque aux humains non je suis tout a
changé et maintenant il ya même des
chasseurs des gt rien
alors vous êtes aymeric contre la
souffrance animale en tout cas c'est
très courageuse et très désintéressée
parce que on n'a jamais vu un port
remercier un dg t'as rien non c'est le
gros problème de la défense du vivant
c'est ça c'est que ceux qui sont les
porte paroles de ce combat se bat pas a
priori pour eux mêmes face et une main
toujours des générations futures mais
rose m'a d'abord pour des êtres vivants
qui qui peuvent pas le faire car il veut
pas s'exprimer alors en parlant de bord
le mouvement balances ton sport vous a
beaucoup choqué parce que pour valve
n'est pas le mouvement par mouvement
mais le mollah la drague oui si c'est
pas cool pour les porcs en génie dommage
d'avoir choisi un hashtag spéciste il
aurait été préférable de choisir balance
son harceleur ou balance dans van steen
mais c'est pas le mouvement lui-même que
je remettais en couple je n'ai aucun
jugement sur le monde s'était en effet
je voudrais que le combat antispécistes
passe aussi par le combat du vocabulaire
et c'est vrai que le port est quand même
l'un des animaux aujourd'hui qui m
souffre le plus dans l'exploitation
animale le porc est un animal qui est
encore plus intelligent que le chien
voilà c'est un animal qui qui très
affectueux qui est bref qui ressent
énormément aux chiens et auxquels on
fait subir aujourd'hui des traitements
actuellement atroce c'est donc ce serait
bien déjà qu'on arrête de l'assimiler un
animal dégueulasse odieux etc mais vous
connaissez des porcs qui ont été
attristés par le hashtag non
non en fait il aurait mieux valu
employés balance son dauphin pourquoi
les dauphins sont obsédés par le sexe
ils sont des violeurs va ils violent les
dorian des dauphins ils violent et il
faut chez les marsouins ah oui les tuent
les tuiles il joue avec alors et 1040
êtes ici ce soir pour nous parler de
votre nouveau livre utopia 21 publié
chez flammarion où vous exposer la
société dont vous rêvez
non
oulala
or nous proposer un chemin vers l'utopie
un monde où les fils des écouteurs de
téléphone ne s'en mêle pas quand on les
sort de sa poche
[Rires]
alors non vous dites l'humanité n'a
progressé que grâce aux rêves sans rêves
l'être humain se perd c'est vrai l'aigle
et grands combats moreau ont été menées
par des gens qu'on a traité de fou
d'utopistes l'occurrence d'après les
premières personnes qui se sont élevé
contre l' esclavage par exemple sont des
gens qui ont fait rire beaucoup ouais
parce qu'à l'époque on pense encore que
l'esclavagé tête une chose naturelle que
vraiment les noirs étaient des êtres
inférieurs aux îles les droits des
femmes même chose le problème c'est que
les deux dernières utopie que nous ayons
vécu ces communisme qui a tué plus de
gens que nazisme et l'ultralibéralisme
qui détruit la planète pour amasser des
profits donc c'est vrai que mais on n'a
pas inquiet quand on entend parler de
l'utopie maintenant non ne pas être
inquiet parce que qu'est ce qu'elle est
le choix qui est le nôtre aujourd'hui
accepter le monde dans lequel on vit le
c'est à dire faire un peu ce que fait
macron et toutes ces équipes là toutes
les équipes qui tournent qui qui prônent
la même idéologie c'est de dire il n'ya
qu'un seul monde possible c'est celui là
alors on peut essayer de d'amendé un
tout petit peu le néolibéralisme essayer
de calmer certains de ses excès mais il
ya aujourd'hui on serait dans le
meilleur des mondes possibles il n'y a
pas de meilleur système il imaginable
j'y crois pas du tout je pense qu'au
contraire il faut aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui par des objectifs
extrêmement ambitieux en repensant
complètement tous les paradigmes et
tenir compte en revanche des erreurs du
passé par exemple de toutes les erreurs
du communisme s'est quant à lui plaint
effectivement le livre s'appelle donc
utopia 21 il est publié chez flammarion
est alors en ethiopie les animateurs
radio et télé non le drame c'est vrai
qu'une seule émission ouais c'est vrai
qu'hier mois on it opi par exemple je
préfère celle du samedi mais pas celle
du dimanche sauf si on considère qu'ils
savent c'est la même en vacances et nos
dîners maison non en fait c'est parce
que pour être tout à fait franc quand
j'ai écrit ce passage je pensais au fait
que dans les médias il ya beaucoup de
gens
de gauche qui prône des idées sociales
mais ça gêne absolument pas de cumuler
trois émissions télé en radio ailleurs
et caetera et d'accumuler le maximum
d'argent donc je trouve ça extrêmement
étrange parce que pour moi ou utopie
c'est déjà le partage du travail des
hommes
c'est plutôt des hommes ben oui oui des
hommes par rapport aux femmes tu veux
dire mais oui oui oui
bien différencier les hommes et les
femmes soient
informés c'est important pour moi la vie
est un repère ça peut être
ça m'aide à faire le distinguo ce nom
mais aymeric grad sur moi il ya des
choses plus importantes dans ton libre à
avant je me suis cachée quand j'ai
commencé je vais là dessus que toute la
ville j'ai comparé ces parcelles parce
que ça nous convient vous senti un petit
peu visé
aller dans son sens si thierry garde
toutes ses émissions
alors en 8e puis les cigarettes sont
interdits plombe c'est vrai je sais
c'est un peu chaud oui tout simplement
parce que alors que je prône une liberté
leur voix la plus grande possible la
plus grande possible pour tous les
citoyens aux pieds avec un nombre de
lois minimale en revanche et même le
droit pour chacun de se faire du mal qui
ont envie je suis contre l'idée d'un
état paternaliste qui va imposer une
forme de loi morale sur chacun en
revanche la cigarette quand on est un
fait si c'est quand même un objet
fabriqué qui fait du mal à tout le monde
à commencer par celui qui l'utilisent et
qui lui procure même pas un réel plaisir
c'est à dire que souvent la cigarette
devient simplement un une envie qu'on a
et génère une frustration s'est tout à
coup on ne fume pas mais c'est pas tout
et tu prends vraiment dans une
dépendance exactement nous faire
poignarder à prier l'alcool simplement
partir les tranquillisants lorsque un
vin par exemple un bon vin il ya un vrai
plaisir gustatif par exemple à savourer
un vin de l'impôt si bon peut-être j'en
sais rien c'est passé je ne sais pas ce
que disait il est toujours interdit de
cigarette en temps et je viens c'est ce
que le petit terrain petit je vais finir
sur la cigarette sur cigarette tout
simplement c'est parce que ça détruit
tout ça détruit des vies de ceux qui
utilisent ce projet coup double elle
s'est énormément d'argent la société
pour les soigner et ça ça nuit également
à l'entourage de ceux qui fument way qui
peuvent qui peuvent également être
victimes du tabagisme ne vois pas
tellement le bénéfice pour la société ou
pour ce bon l'interview chances pour que
tout ceci je vois oui thierry vous
perdez votre tendre vous donne des
nouvelles de l'audimat vous avez beau
cirer les pompes d'aymeric caron les
animaux ne nous regarde toujours
en utopie la propriété immobilière était
interdite ouais mais on n'a pas le droit
d'avoir un appartement non là c'est une
idée extrêmement simple c'est à dire que
je pense que la propriété immobilière
génère par définition une profonde
injustice d'abord je considère que le
vivant n'appartient à personne or
l'immobilier par définition c'est
d'abord une captation du vivant c'est un
terrain trop bon ça c'est une petite
maison en banlieue et d'où vient ce
terrain comment la personne avant s'est
approprié ce terrain tous tout tout tout
les propriétés privées aujourd'hui sont
fondées d'abord sur une injustice
fondamentale qui est une forme de
violence qui a permis de capter cette
propriété on a joué on a battu et des
indiens pour asile gino russo et
impacter tous les bijoux sow rousseau et
a juste changé un navire russe
souhaitait premier à le dire que l'un
des plus gros problème a commencé le
jour où quelqu'un mines clôture ouais et
a dit c'est chez moi ornithologie écoute
bien clovis chacun reçoit 2000 euros par
mois en échange de 15 heures de travail
par semaine moi je suis d'accord
d'accord c'est 2000 simplement pour que
les tabous verse un salaire voilà qui
vous permet de subvenir absolument à
tous vos besoins intérêt général oui
c'est à dire qu'en gros on calcule un
peu toute la masse de travail qui est
nécessaire pour faire fonctionner la
société dans absolument tous les
domaines on considère que se
répartissent à de manière équitable
entre tous les citoyens en âge de
travailler dont il ya plus de chômage du
tout on peut arriver à peu près même la
15 heures en revanche au delà de ces 15
heures chacun est libre de travailler
quand même tu as plus pour gagner plus
avec tout de même une limite 10000 euros
par an à maxime et au delà on reverse on
redistribue way lâchant que ces mesures
là bien évidemment dépendent d'autres
mesures comme on le disait il ya plus de
propriétés privées donc tout est moins
cher près nos crises et c'est que des
gens nés très riche chanteurs qu'ils ont
un million d'albums il va gagner dix
mille euros par mois way est un plombier
casse à petit son entreprise il peut
gagner dix mille donc tout le monde
gagne 10 mise non le oui c'est le
plombier cumul enfin ils ont bien aura
droit de chanter ou comment ce que
j'essaie d'expliquer par rapport aux
salaires et l art et au fait que je
souhaite en effet dans ma société idéale
que les cerfs soit beaucoup plus
équilibrée c'est que le cantonnier par
exemple qui fabrique une route way est
aussi important que le médecin qui va
vous recevoir à l'hôpital si vous avez
tout à coup un groupe et un voudrait
bien aller à cet hôpital est donc le
médecin c'est pas normal qu'ils gagnent
cinq ou six fois plus que le cantonnier
parce que d'une certaine manière chacun
participe au bon fonctionnement la
société or nous avons décrété qu'il y
avait des fonctions plus noble qui
devait être plus valorisé que d'autres
n'ont pas de crédit se fait
naturellement en fait oui enfin
quelqu'un qui a dit toi tu vas gagner ça
veut dire gagner ça il y à des
mécanismes sont mis en plateau n'y ai
que de bons médecins jacob thoniers
proctologue il vous fait les deux
y avait des affiches si c'est une
histoire de 6 et une histoire de qualité
parce qu'on peut lui se questionne
également sur effectivement la validité
d'un salaire il ya des mets tes
aujourd'hui absolument inutile dans
lesquels on peut gagner sept huit neuf
mille euros mais quel bois par exemple
dans les métiers de la finance qui sert
strictement à rien pour la société
tandis que des médiations fondamentaux
comme infirmier oui alors comme ça vient
comme étant sa dernière sur droit s'est
payé s'est pas passé comme une
infirmière gagne 1800 euros je suis
d'accord pour sauver des vies c'est ça
dont on parle pour sauver des vies ça
permet à peine de vivre dans une
interview elle a rencontré l'assentiment
général pc sac récemment
en utopie
le mariage est supprimé
oui alors à titre personnel je pense en
effet que ma jeune et n'est plus tout à
fait une institution adapté à notre
époque là ce qui est bien c'est que vous
dites que dans l'avenir il y aura des
mariages à 2 à 3 4 pas con avec des
animaux mais non j'ai pas peur prévu les
animaux non humains mais en effet je
pensais c'est une construction
complètement archaïque avec un fort sens
que le religieux d'ailleurs qui fait qu'
on s'est dit un jour aller on va se
marier puis on va se mettre fidélité
pour la vie ça correspond pas tout
simplement je pense à la réalité c'est
romain aujourd'hui alors si la voix oui
thierry d'inquiétude ici au standard
est-ce qu'on utopie on sera obligé de
lire les bouquins d'aymeric cornes
je vais y penser
ce qu'on vise c'est quand même plus
inquiétant el marikh c'est que si les
gens ne sont pas d'accord vous êtes très
à employer la méthode forte et non en à
vous dites qu'ils attaquent par les uns
répondrons par les armes bien évidemment
on ne sait pas ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que je dis que
chacune des mesures que je propose ouais
là je souhaite qu'elle soit mise en
place après une validation par
référendum par exemple du peuple le
peuple est consulté en rien aujourd'hui
quasiment rien si on prend l'exemple un
exemple récent les les vaccins bien
puisque ça vient d'entrer en vigueur
aujourd'hui la vaccination pour les
enfants est obligatoire à 11 vaccin vous
avez vu un débat là-dessus alors que
c'est quand même une mesure extrêmement
contestable et contesté donc s'est
imposé je tire qu'une des mesures
devraient être validées par le peuple
comme bassin pour poser la question oui
mais alors s'il ya des gens qui sont pas
d'accord qui se rebellent par hommes qui
veulent pas rendre leur appartement bas
la loi sera là pour les gens qui est une
mesure qui a été prise par le peuple par
la majorité du peuple est aujourd'hui
593 camp mais non aujourd'hui quand
quelqu'un ne respectent pas la loi et à
bien des aviales chez lui à bien des
policiers c'est juste la loi mais c'est
une société non violente pardon
intéristes réside encore vous dit que on
va consulter le peuple en 2005 on a
résulté le peuple sur la constitution
européenne on a fait quand même notre
dame des landes le peuple était pour la
construction de l'aéroport ont le feu
n'a pas encore si son lot de sorties et
l'indépendance on ne fait pas donc
encore faut-il que les avis du peuple
soit respectée on est absolument bien
sûr alors moi je trouve quand même que
vous avez changé parce que il ya 25 ans
vous avez été bouleversé par la mort
d'un hérisson que vous avez écrasé la
nuit sur une route est-ce que je vous
attends durci suffisamment pour porter
la révolution mais que vous prenez
aymeric
en tout cas la sensibilité vis-à-vis du
monde animal elle n'a fait que se
renforcer alors les arguments de ce
livre on les retrouve dans la tribune
que vous avez publié dans le monde je
dis vous y annoncer la fondation d'une
nouvelle organisation politique le
rassemblement des écologistes pour le
vivant ces belles rêve or dans le
manifeste suppression de la chasse la
corrida les français sont opposés on
parlait de démocratie et un national des
français veulent aujourd'hui qu'on
rénove complètement la chasse ils sont
par exemple l'interdiction la chasse que
dimanche ils sont aujourd'hui aux trois
quarts les français pour l'interdiction
totale de la corrida avec mise à mort en
tout cas on voit bien que le
gouvernement n'écoute absolument pas la
majorité des fonds c'est la majorité du
peuple sur ces questions à nous bien
évidemment aujourd'hui dans une société
on voit bien que énormément de pays
d'europe avance sur ces questions du
bien-être animal et que nous fait du
surplace hillion recul même avec
emmanuel macron il ya la décroissance
aussi mais ça c'est une nécessité ah ça
oui je vous dire pour du gers et
honnêtement l'armée d'accord je pense
sincèrement que le libéralisme le
capitalisme est l'ennemi de l'écologie
vont vouloir réconcilier capitalisme
écologie c'est une connerie ça laisse
admirer son auxiliaire ben ça ne peut
pas faire tout ça c'est du pipeau je
suis assez d'accord avec vous savez
c'est parce que ces idées là c'est pas
celle d'un dangereux gauchistes c'est
celle sont les idées de quelqu'un qui
essaye simplement de regarder le monde
tel qu'il est il ya quinze mille
scientifiques qui ont publié une tribune
il ya deux mois qui a été relayée dans
énormément de jour d'aucun je me sens
civique de 184 pays pour dire exactement
ce que vous venez de time c'est à dire
que en effet il faut maintenant
commencer à penser a déclaré on sent
tout cas la limitation de la
consommation que il n'en faut trouver
une autre planète il faut trouver une
peine d south stephen hawking
l'astrophysicien le dit il faut trouvera
sans doute trouvé nos plaies 10 6 500
ans alors il ya une phrase que que vous
aimez beaucoup
que je trouve évidemment très bien c'est
si tu renonce à tes rêves tu meurs
simplement ces extraits de flashdance
n'irait c'est bien ce que les gens site
des grands philosophes ou visitez flash
dance to he may well espèce de snobisme
qui fait que surtout en france 1 parce
qu'on est hyper snob en france avec la
question intellectuelle on met les gens
dans des cases donc par exemple
certainement si on veut défendre une
idée politique on va se référer qu'à des
penseurs politiques on va souhaiter
tocqueville opacité des gens comme ça on
va pas citer effectivement jennifer
beals flashdance au restaurant que la
vie est beaucoup plus complexe que ça
j'adore lire effectivement hannah arendt
schopenhauer ils sont cités d'ailleurs
dans le livre aristote non j'adore
écouter michel berger j'adore certains
films comme flash dance qui ont bercé
mon mot de mon adolescence et je suis
persuadé qu'on se nourrit de tout ce
qu'on trouve dans tous les domaines de
la culture populaire et se trouve que
parfois la culture populaire dit des
choses bien plus intéressantes que des
gros bouquin de philosophe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
car en je crois que sa team des remous à
vous rendre extrêmement sympathique
auprès des téléspectateurs vraiment je
n'ai
plus un parti et pour montrer finalement
vous vous nourrissez de tous je vous
propose de nous jouer quelque chose au
piano parce que vous chantez très bien
en tête allez-y
[Applaudissements]
et
pourquoi les gens qui s'aiment sont ils
toujours un peu les mêmes
ils ont quand il s'en vient
mais
le seul désir
pour tous
[Musique]
ce sont des gens
pourquoi les gens qui s'est sentie
toujours un peu
reber
taisons l'heure
rien de dire rien à faire
[Musique]
e
ce sont des gens qui se
et most connaît amer
ce serait tu ne sont à rien
2 me
[Musique]
faire
de la place
mais si ça vaut pas la peine
j'y reviens
me dire fou des yeux
quel que soit le temps
que ça fait quelque chose
je veux être nous
bravo
[Applaudissements]
oui j'adore cette chanson j'ai
redécouvert william sheller il ya six
mois hépatite met à la musique ça va
plus rien rapporté qu'on fait
cantonniers
et maintenant on passe à la bataille des
idées du chanteur beck
[Musique]
c'est gilles rivière dickstein
journaliste spécialiste des questions
agricoles et environnementales que nous
retrouverons sur ce plateau après le
magnéto battle de ce soir l'obsession de
manger sain nous rend elle fout
en france on est devenus complètement
parano avec la voûte
en 2013 c'était le cheval roumain dans
les lasagnes
l'an dernier les eaux contaminées au
fipronil et voilà que cette année ce
sont des salmonelles dents de lait pour
bébé
résultat huit français sur dix pensent
que leurs aliments quotidiens représente
un risque pour leur santé en france on
soupçonne volontiers les agriculteurs de
mix empoisonné avec leur explicite
tandis que les industries and tools and
cheats avec leur colorants et leur
conservateur résultat neuf français sur
dix sont convaincus que les produits bio
sont meilleurs pour la santé la bio et
dans ma nature et pourtant ce n'est pas
si simple d'abord il faut rappeler qu
aucune étude scientifique n'a jamais
vraiment prouvé que les produits bio
était meilleure pour la santé ensuite on
oublie souvent que le bio peut sabrer
toxiques souvenez-vous qu'en 2011
quarante sept personnes sont mortes
empoisonnées par des graines germées
cultivées dans une ferme biologique en
allemagne en réalité le bio est devenu
un argument marketing lol je suis tout
seul du jus de truffe et jus d'orange
claire vont rester en bonne santé pour
passer à la caisse selon ufc que choisir
les grandes surfaces vendent les fruits
et légumes 80 % plus cher quand c'est du
bio pas étonnant que le nouveau patron
de carrefour adore le bio plus de bio
pour tout le monde carrefour jo petits
biscuits alexandre bompard a prévu de
multiplier par 4 son chiffre d'affaires
dans le bio d'ici 2022 croyez vraiment
que c'est parce qu'ils se soucient de la
santé de ses clients en réalité la
grande distribution s'adapte aux
nouvelles tendances la preuve carrefour
propose désormais une gamme de plats
vegan qui ont été validés par
l'association l214
vous savez ceux qui filment les
abattoirs pour nous dégoûter de la
viande à force de nous culpabiliser l214
a marqué des points si ça continue ce
sera bientôt tellement mal vu de manger
de la viande que des grandes surfaces
d'autres plus en proposer dans l'oreille
chez les messieurs de blacko mise en
image de julien gracq gilles et des
biens reichstag bonsoir
la journaliste spécialiste des questions
agricoles alimentaires est votre dernier
livre tannique dans l'assiette ils se
nourrissent de nos peurs et paris en
2010 est aux éditions du public erp
bienvenue parmi nergie selon un sondage
ipsos les français sont de plus en plus
inquiet de la qualité de leurs produits
alimentaires 70 % disent consommer
davantage de produits bons pour la santé
et ils sont 27% en france à manger bio
mais est ce que l'on tombe pas
finalement dans la parano voir la
psychose l'obsession de manger ça nous
rend elle fout alors gilles vous dites
depuis quelques années des nouvelles
peurs alimentaires sont apparus les
conservateurs les colorants les ogm et
les médias amplifient la croyance
finalement selon eux manger serait
devenu une activité à risque
c'est ça que vous dites je dis qu'il ya
une vraie en fabrique de la peur qui
s'est installé en france et qui sort ce
sur les peurs alimentaires lorsqu'il
faut bien savoir c'est quelle plan
élémentaire ont toujours existé bien sûr
mais avant ce qu'on a mais c'est surtout
peur de ne rien avoir dans son assiette
vue et puis on avait aussi ses peurs des
intoxications ce qui est normal de roi
c'est encore c'est pas tout à fait
éliminer c'était les deux principales
peur que kate est légitime sur cet art
alimentaire depuis une dizaine d'années
une quinzaine d'années il ya une
fabrique de l'apr commerciale dont le
but si vous voulez c'est effectivement
de faire en sorte que des gens achètent
de nouveaux produits avec des vertus
presque subliminale je dirais et que
bien entendu ils sont toujours un tout
petit peu plus cher le paradoxe est
c'est dû sans sucre c'est plus cher du
sans colorant c'est plus cher du sens
elle c'est plus cher du sans pesticides
c'est plus cher mais son aux jeunes
c'est plus cher et donc vous avez
toujours si vous voulez une tendance
aujourd'hui qui se développe dans la
grande distribution pas simplement de
surfer sur cette période élémentaire
mais de les alimenter ça que j'appelle
la fabrique de la fin oui à huit
français sur dix aujourd'hui son inquiet
des effets de l'alimentation sur leur
santé et cette obsession de manger sain
tourne à la pathologie est sain non en
fait ça va l'orthorexie de miel
l'anorexie il ya l'orthorexie c'est un
toc en fait ça devient un toc alors
disons que quand c'est à ce stade alors
c'est vraiment grave ici mais on pense
car entre 1 et 3% de la population qui
sont en train d'être touché par cette
maladie dire que des gens c'est qu'ils
passent au minimum trois heures par jour
à réfléchir à ce qu'ils doivent même
dans leur assiette trois heures salle
c'est très français mais je sens qui
finalement ne peuvent plus être invité
chez l'autre personne parce que s'ils
sont invités chez une personne qui ne
savent plus qui avait présenté dans
l'assiette donc il se met en marche de
la société mais ça ce sont les cas
extrêmes mais entre ces cas extrêmes et
la grande majorité de la population les
peurs alimentaires fonctionne très bien
par exemple le marché du bio a explosé
mais pas parce que les gens aiment
laïque où tu biologique et c'est que ça
représente le point de vue misons
politique comme american le défendre
mais parce qu'ils ont simplement peur
d'être empoisonné comme s'il leur reste
des agriculteurs faisaient du poison
vous avez raison le retour ici est
exploité par les lobbys par les grands
groupes alimentaires pour faire acheter
des produits plus chers en fait sous
prétexte qu'ils sont bio ou sont 600
saint laurent non mais les peurs
alimentaires sont légitimes parce qu'il
ya du poison à toutes les étapes et dans
tous les produits qu'on mange il ya
vingt pesticides dans dans une pomme ce
que tu sais pas mon cher laurent riz
c'est qu'il faudrait ingurgité
25000 on de pommes pour avoir la même
quantité de produits cancérigènes qu'en
buvant un verre de vin rouge même si les
bio c'est à dire que tu vois là tu es
victime de la propagande et et j'ai vu
une cigale fumer une cigarette serré ça
alors là c'est 50 millions de pommes
minimum quoi il faut relativiser les
risques afin de cumuler les risques
c'est que de temps en temps
effectivement les pesticides pas bon
pour la santé c'est clair et les résidus
de pesticides qui peut y avoir sur une
pomme mais il n'y a aucun danger 7-0 en
danger pour le consommateur c'est clair
et net y'a même pas de débat là dessus
ouais mais ça tue pas les habits on
n'achète pas des produits bio pour
sauver les abeilles on achète du produit
parce que la peur pour sa santé oui non
mais qui
vous dit j'achète des produits bio c'est
parce que c'est meilleur pour leur santé
des enfants c'est ce que vous dites il
ya un nouveau territoire d'image en fait
qu'est le naturel le sang alors sans
gluten sans colorant sans sucre sans
pesticides sans conservateur sans
lactose sans ogm en fait par exemple le
gluten en france il ya un pour cent des
gens qui font une allergie au gluten et
1 5 million de connards qui trouvent
sans gluten
c'est après cette mode
attention je dirais pas que ce sont des
connards sur des gens qui m'aiment pas
qu'il ça fait même du bien ouais parce
qu'ils se sentent mieux c'est
psychologique donc ça marche tant mieux
pour eux moi j'ai rien contre ça m'a
fait savoir que c'est c'est
psychologique je n'ai rien d'autre et
une industrie du bien-être grande
distance pour pouvoir vendre les
produits que vous désactive il faut bien
entendu que faisait avant intoxiqué ça
ça sert à rien ouais donc toute la gamme
de produits achetés pour vous
désintoxiquer c'est parce qu'avant on a
convaincu que vous êtes intoxiqué et
votre organisme vous et dan désintoxique
très bien il est fait pour
vous n'êtes pas besoin de tout ça voir
marquer ça alors
j'imagine que vous bouffer du sans
gluten sans colorant sans match un
pouvoir y est victime des peurs
alimentaires finalement pas forcément
moi d'abord mon rapport à la nourriture
les différents qui se base sur sous le
rapport que j'ai à l'éthique et à notre
manière de considérer le vivant et
notamment évidemment le vivant animal
d'autre part c'est vrai que je fais très
attention à la santé et je crois en ce
qui me concerne que les pesticides ont
un effet négatif pour la santé des gens
il ya des études qui parle de rêve de
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
victimes à cause des pesticides je pense
qu'à des produits naturels qui est quand
même son meilleur à manger que des
produits qui eux sont bourrés de
produits chimiques des sucres dont 35 en
musique par exemple à cambridge bourrés
de produits chimiques sera bourré de
produits chimiques impétrants ses
produits changent pas les piqûres de
produits chimiques dans les pommes bas
dans l'avion le oui oui oui ce que je
vais dire c'est à dire 2 en fait c'est
sûr que ça fait pas du bien les
pesticides mais mais il ya un moment où
on dit picasso moi je vais vous dire
quand je mange une pomme maintenant j'ai
peur
j'ai plus je me dis est-ce que j'enlève
la peau eva eu la même réaction nommé
victimes de la fabrique de la pâte bien
sûr là est vrai qu'on a toujours eu un
rapport à la nature particuliers liés
effectivement à la crainte la crainte de
ce qu'on ingurgite parce que cet acte là
est très particulier de mettre quelque
chose dans son béarn est dans l'histoire
c'est cette fois c'est comme ça il ya
quand même un phénomène particulier
depuis la seconde guerre mondiale c'est
l'industrie agroalimentaire qui a quand
même changé considérablement notre
rapport à la nourriture et on a très
très peu de recul sur bon nombre de
pratiques actuelles donc je veux bien
qu'on dise il ya aucun risque aucun
risque le fait est que sur beaucoup de
sujets on n'en sait rien et sur les ogm
on a pu par exemple inspirant exogènes
on a quand même de sérieuses raisons
d'avoir peur quand on voit un certain
nombre de d'études qui existe christine
je trouve que si on parle d'éthique je
mange pas de produits où il ya 2 il de
palme par ce que j'ai vu qu'ils avaient
plus de 30 ans à cause de l'huile de
palme donc ça c'est éthique pour le
reste je bouffe tout ce que j'ai envie
de bouffer chanteur bah voilà mr le bio
je trouve qu'une tomate que j'achète
chez un producteur bio elle a plus de
goût qu'une tomate floaters qui vient de
célébrer ce pesticide si je peux pas m
capable ya pas deux
thomas différentes la bio et non bio il
ya une multitude de variétés différentes
certains sont plus goûteuse du sucre est
plus salée plus faire moins ferme
certains ne voulait m'utiliser pour
faire là vous êtes en train de faire
l'apologie du bio parce que d'état des
détails des différentes notes ça
n'existe plus du tout dans l'industrie
alimentaire que tu ne sais pas aymeric
et peut-être c'est que les tomates bio
sont élevées au sol c'est à dire que
c'est des plants de tomates qui ont
juste la pointe de la tomate qui baigne
dans un dans un bain biologique et qu'en
fait il me dit tout simplement que quand
on dit il ya des tas d espèces de
tomates aujourd'hui l'industrie
agroalimentaire fait on fait une
réduction de toutes les espèces
végétales possible avec des modèles
uniques
dans les magasins voyez bien que
variétés de tomates à un duel non bio et
les plus grandes heures c'est la même
chose dans le blé coup pour redonner
petit exor à petit exemple dans le grès
be le blé violeuse lévis au blé bio et
ben fait une variété de blé c'est le
revenant il ya une variété de blé parce
que c'est le plus résistantes donc j'ai
pas du tout vrai vous jouais très bien
au piano pour l'agriculture il hésite
sept coups sûrs
alors autour des noms français en des
potagers moi mes tomates elles sont sur
ma terrasse de dire elles sont bio way
70 jours parce que avec l'air de paris
lyne ramona mais elles sont élevées au
gaz carbonique détrompez-vous on a le
meilleur miel le miel de par les toits
de paris laurent toi tu es [ __ ] par la
peur alimentaire j'ai bien conscience
que le bio ce soit une machine à fric et
que les grandes enseignes se goinfrent
là-dessus mais je venais ainsi n'ayant
pas confiance et je sais que chaque
produit porteur d'une dose extrêmement
toxique pour l'organisme alors est-ce
que le véganisme est une orthorexie
est-ce que c'est pas une maladie mentale
le véganisme c'est à dire battre le mois
l'appel d'urgence moi je dirais que non
parce que quand je disais tout à l'heure
je pense qu'il ya une éthique d'ailleurs
en tout cas un certain cas pour
certaines personnes pour d'autres ça
peut être une autre rexie mais bon ça se
porte pas sur un aliment ça se porte sur
un ensemble ça veut dire que c'est
vraiment des gens qui regardent tout
ceci dit il ya des gens effectivement
qui vont instrumentalisée vous imaginez
bien que les marchands de soja et de
sting de cela il faut bien que les gens
qui vient tourner alors kim justement
aymeric caron pour convertir les gens
véganisme dit la viande tue la viande
tue deux fois elle tue l'animal et elle
vêtue vous donc est ce que là on n'est
pas dans la création d'une peur
alimentaire pour imposer une idéologie
vega n'y
a qu'un appartement mon arrivée à terme
et quelques ouvrages je ne m'y attendais
pas
vous faites référence à des études
extrêmement sérieuse pour le coup qui
ont simplement montrer et prouver que
l'excès de viande de viande rouge
notamment favoriser les maladies
cardiovasculaires certain nombre de
cancers ce genre de choses fin 2017 des
chercheurs de l'université de bristol en
angleterre
ont vérifié qu'ils avaient un risque de
dépression de déprime deux fois plus
élevé chez les végétariens bas et le
provins à cause de carences membres à
cause de carences en vitamines et en
ayrault voilà donc moi je vais bien
bouffer décalé mais si je devais devenir
encore plus triste ça va être terrible
ça peut être pour ça qu'il ya ça
développe une certaine vision du monde
un peu pessimiste aussi peu tard et
après les chaleurs c'est l'escale france
comme la vision et les plus tôt elle est
plutôt le point d études mais si même si
moi j'appuie mes travaux toujours sur
des études c'est que vous quand même
bien
puiser ses sources parce que regarder
l'heure en tout cas comment elles ont
été faites parce qu'il ya quand même
beaucoup qui disent absolument n'importe
qui s'il voit oui vous raconter
n'importe quoi je viens de manger une
pomme et je n'ai aucune
s'il arrive avec sa merci d'avancé
[Musique]
tennis amis il sonne la touchante est
toujours en compagnie de christine bravo
issiar dia même rythme qu'en novembre
et
l'on m'a dit
et maintenant c'est l'heure des infos
devises aux as
il
bonsoir à tous bonsoir fériés et on va
attaquer directement par la politique
française
emmanuel macron était une fois de plus
en visite à l'étranger cette semaine il
s'est rendu en corse
l'occasion de mettre en lumière l'île de
beauté avec notamment ce sondage 74 %
des français sont opposés à
l'indépendance de la corse et on va le
voir sur ce graphique donc seulement 26
% des français ont répondu qu'ils
étaient favorables à l'indépendance cas
c'est la question qui sera posée le
sondeur de bfm tv on voit que les
chiffres évoluent si c'est un
indépendantiste corse qui pose la
question là c'est toujours 26% pour
seulement 52 contre et 22 % préfèrent ne
pas se prononcer dans ce cadre c'est
normal et c'est encore plus flagrant
quand c'est un indépendantiste corse
cagoulés il vous pose la question
suivante
à temps que j'y suis d'autres chiffres
sachant que l'accord s'intéresse comme
beaucoup les français le peuple corse
alors notamment sur le sentiment
d'identité encore sur l'île 12% des
corses se sentent avant tout européen 15
% se sentent avant tout français oui 1
35 % se sentent avant tout corse et 45 %
se sentent avant tout fatigué ça c'est
important de le dire
[Applaudissements]
dernier chiffre pour contredire quand
tous ces clichés l'espérance de vie
encore ces biens est une des plus hautes
en europe et les mêmes plus haute que
caen métropole espérance de vie pour un
homme en corse c'est à peu près 79 ans
pour une femme encore ses 84 ans en
revanche pour une paillotes en corse et
au havre moins de dix ans et mon
espérance de vie si je prends des
vacances en corse après cette chronique
et bien voilà c'est presque zéro
revenons sur le contenu recherché par la
police le fichier s était en fait un
voisin de gérard collomb et ouais ça la
grosse info c'est que gérard collomb
apparemment il n'était pas à la fête des
voisins l'année dernière sinon il
l'aurait repéré oui mais ça peut arriver
à tout le monde parfois on cherchait
clés et puis on sent qu'on qu'est sa
poche et est du coup je me dis peut-être
l'avion de la malaisienne airlines est
ce qu'ils ont pensé à regarder sur la
piste de l'aéroport de cologne
chercher dans ma poche droite et elle
était dans la poche gauche commence à
retrouver à la fin du film à la société
france au 1er mars voilà le paquet de
cigarettes augmentera de 1 euro bam
alors la bonne nouvelle pour les fumeurs
rassurez-vous le prix de la chimio lui
reste inchangé
alors tout cas le jour où intermarché va
faire une promotion de -70% sur les
cartouches de marlboro s'arrête une
hécatombe
internationale le président brésilien
forcé de prouver qu'il est vivant pour
toucher sa retraite c'est quoi la caisse
de retraite de michel py maire a exigé
qui se présente en personne dans ses
bureaux pour prouver qu'il était encore
en vie on rigole on rigole mais
heureusement qu'on ne demande pas la
même chose en algérie abdelaziz
bouteflika est pas près de toucher 1
dinar
international toujours avec une
fusillade en italie et on a découvert
que mein kampf était chez l'auteur de
cette fusillade racistes alors bon c'est
vrai que quand on voit comment christine
angot s'énerve après avoir lu un mauvais
livre heureusement qu'elle n'est pas
inscrite dans un club de tir
[Applaudissements]
suite à la sphère tariq ramadan des
témoignages d'anciens élèves en suisse
ressurgissent et il aurait notamment eu
des relations avec des étudiantes âgées
de 15 ans et en même temps un mec qui
s'appelle ramadan on peut pas lui
reprocher de se taper le jeune
petit jeu de mots de qualité et passons
au pape le pape françois s'élève contre
les fake news non au fait que news alors
exemple est-ce que c'est pas un peu se
tirer une balle dans le pied
je vais vous montrer parce que les gens
vous voient pas de sur la différence
entre news effective ou alors on va
faire un petit jeu a par exemple ceux ci
une jeune vierge tombe enceinte de dieu
bon fait venir où l'ue en revanche ivre
virgules une jeune vierge tombe enceinte
de dieu à ça ça peut vraiment être une
info on continue le petit jeu de l'eau
transformée en vain la fiq news le
beaujolais nouveau est arrivé à ça c'est
rien pour
et la dernière un jeune homme marche sur
l'eau fait que news triste fin pour le
petit grégory voilà
alors people
dany boon se domicilient chez moi en
belgique il vient habiter chez nous à
uccle bah dis donc il prépare une suite
pour son film rien à déclarer qui de
votre visage s'appelait pas envie de
déclarer
et people toujours babacar regret de ne
pas avoir été invité aux funérailles de
france gall et c'est vrai que moi j'ai
entendu j'ai pas mal de gens aux
funérailles de france gall qui disait
papa cas où es tu
idem pour christine que tout est vrai je
ne les invente alors est ce que c'est
important de dire sport l'idiot de
pyeongchang alors 1200 agents de
sécurité terrassé par une épidémie de
gastro entérite sont contraints
d'abandonner leur poste alors voilà bah
on sait déjà qui veut décrocher le
bronze
[Applaudissements]
elle est belle elle y est
les brèves
belgique elle tente de tuer sa
grand-mère en l'empoisonnant avec des
crêpes pour pouvoir toucher l'héritage
et ouais mais c'est complètement idiot
si elle avait utilisé un peu de lait
lactalis elle est peut-être arrivé
tranquille kazakhstan elle coupe le
pénis de son mari parce que il a
complimenté une autre femme ouais mais
non attention elle l'avait prévenu elle
m'a dit si tu la regardes la prochaine
fois tu apportes à mettre derrière
l'oreille et baba il y arrive et jose
états unis une jeune femme retrouve son
père biologique effet un enfant avec lui
belge croit il donne plutôt envie le
nouveau scénario de woody allen
[Rires]
allez c'est la culture
à thierry vous avez ça quand je vous
fait visiter l'exposition va à nice au
mamac qui nous invite à découvrir la
rétrospective de la sculpteure
canadienne liz may gorce et jusqu'au 30
mai alors on la reconnaît assez
facilement c'est la fille cachée de jean
pierre coffe et d'eva joly
c'est une artiste plasticienne
installations liste alors ça donne
l'impression que le pareil beaucoup mais
en réalité c'est quand même un peu une
grosse feignasse son devoir sa première
heure je dirais la même pas pensé
depuis plus de 40 ans un lise madore
elle interroge notre quotidien notre
folie de l'achat compulsif et
l'accumulation des objets notamment les
vêtements on va voir ici voici sorte de
compression dhabi laisser ma gorge un
peu la césar mais du hr et et puis l
état doit faire très plaisir aux enfants
three enquête se dire tiens on a
participé nous aussi à une oeuvre d'art
et d'un autre côté si on retourne
regarder si on retourne l'oeuvre eh bien
on voit qu'elle a dissimulé derrière des
vêtements une cartouche de cigarettes et
on se dit que ça ressemble quand même
beaucoup au contenu d'une valise de
quelqu'un de corée fait un go fast à
andorre
est dans la même lignée voilà ça c'est
une de ses oeuvres ce sont les moufles
de johnny hallyday
quand ce ne sont pas des cigarettes et
bien non il ya aussi ça voilà une offre
qui pourrait peut-être vous plaire
christine et
et parfois parfois ce sont des montages
plus rigolo comme ici on voit ses bas
c'est françois bayrou qui essayent de
rattraper sa carrière politique et on le
reconnaît c'est aux oreilles cole qu'on
leur connaît autre oeuvre assez étrange
âmes sensibles s'abstenir on reconnaît
voilà ça c'est là c'est la teuf de
donald trump
[Applaudissements]
et parfois ils utilisent de la
nourriture ça c'est assez marrant en
fait ici elle a créé la première tranche
de jambon relié avec une sortie usb et
donc on peut vraiment ici par les deux
ports usb et wej abatteurs dans ce beau
et elle a été plus loin en créant la
chaise gens beaux voyez comment c'est
alors la police française a déjà
commandé une dizaine de ces chaises pour
les interrogatoires de djihadistes
relève est là dessus avec valence est
et pour conclure la dernière
installation qui résume un peu tous et
une pile d'assiettes avec de la bouffe
des clubs de l'alcool des médicaments il
ya même un rat mort une oeuvre que
j'imaginais la sobre blanc intitulé
panne de lave vaisselle chez michel
houellebecq
allez donc au mamac pourvoir lise madore
parce que là c'est comme la politique
hier tout autant par les bravades c'est
un épisode
si l'apple motion sur soi
selon m
et on passe maintenant à notre thé au
top de la semaine
[Musique]
sacrement soir
alors que rice 60 films en 35 ans je
vais dire que dans le porno où on peut
se dire
je crois que les gars qui font du porno
arrive à faire plusieurs porno dans une
semaine oui donc facilement pourrait
s'en trouver une courte carrière pour un
gars du
panama le temps que tu as ton trop on se
veut dire quand même que clovis c'est
pas bon alors voilà nous dit travailler
ça veut dire se lever le matin et aller
bosser voilà c'est une phrase qui ramène
à la réalité quoi parce que c'est celle
là bah oui parce que vos parents ou
myriam boyer et roger cornillac était
dans le métier elle comédienne lui de
metteur en scène et vous les avez vus en
baver et vous avez su très tôt que ce
métier on le faisait pas pour la gloire
et l'argent je c'est parce qu'on n'y
croyait en ba vi et simplement parce que
ils ont toujours travaillé non c'est pas
des vedettes c'est pas des voilà donc
j'avais une notion une conscience du
métier denis bien voilà tu fais un choix
n'est pas blindé de pognon tepa a jamais
été atteint donc quelque chose mais si
ces acteurs ouais et c'est vrai vous
voyez votre mère avec des gens que ce
soir avec m ils ont une formidable mejia
montador est tout sauf qu'il la faisait
pas beau c'est quoi donc ça y est c'est
à dire qu'un moment quand tout le monde
te dis que quelqu'un est formidable il
s'avère que cette amère mais que
formidable c'est génial et où il fait
mais bon pourquoi alors pourquoi vous
n'apprenez pas dans ce film là dans soul
man alors elle n'a jamais manqué de
travail parce que c'est une sublime
actrice mais il n'empêche que je trouve
qu'à une forme d'injustice qui est que
j'ai découvert 13 ans à 14 ans vous
quitter le domicile maternel vous
installer dans une chambre de bonne et à
15 ans vous tournez votre premier film
ouais en la loi 15 ans et demi
wen était chouette c'était une super
aventure parce que j'étais venu pour
faire une panouille et puis à l'arrivée
un moment ni tu vas avoir le premier
rôle donc c'était des bonbons et la très
rapidement vous travaillez des grands
metteurs en scène de théâtre
frey peter brook trek alain françon
ouais quand je fais le premier film hors
la loi comme c'est un film très cher
pour l'époque et qui a fait un four le
cinéma m'a jeté mais alors ouais ouais
c'était radical et j'ai eu et surtout de
la chance parce que dès que je perdais
quelque chose quelque chose aux frères
moi donc c'est super chouette de la
joseph clovis qu'on appelle un enfant de
la balle
ça fait mal
et ça sera valable du consentement
à l'enfant de la base de l'us cognac
de 2008 à 2013 vous êtes dans tous les
films au fait cinq films par an c'était
soit vous soit kad merad ce n'est pas
compliqué vous êtes tous les deux
monsieur tout le monde du cinéma
français à l'époque très probablement je
veux dire à un moment ils ont pensé aux
césars a créé une catégorie meilleur
film avec clovis cornillac quoi
tellement vous avez autres films bien
jour vous décidé de ne plus faire qu'un
film par an c'est après avoir vu astérix
aux jeux olympiques
non j'étais très déçu effectivement de
du film j'ai adoré le faire en revanche
mais pourquoi un moment vous décidé de
ne plus faire qu'un film par an alors
c'est en fait j'ai plutôt décidé à un
moment de d'arrêter de tourner c'est à
dire d'arrêter de jouer j'avais besoin
de stopper un truc qui était le film en
plus est comme ça faisait un petit
moment que ça me travaillait et que
j'avais une histoire à raconter mais si
au moins essaye de fabriquer un film we
java de changer ça va te faire du bien
mais en 2010 à l'époque j'étais un
acteur populaire vous déclarez je sais
que je ne suis pas un réalisateur et
pourtant ensuite vous réalisez un peu
beaucoup aveuglément c'est plutôt bien
foutu et quatre épisodes de la série
chef pour france 2 donc j'ai tjrs est un
des acteurs et ce soit vous êtes ici
comme acteur mais aussi comme
réalisateur parce que j'ai continué dans
cette idée de réaliser des films
maintenant ça vous plaît beaucoup et le
film que vous avez réalisé c'est belle
et sébastien 3 le dernier chapitre qui
sort le 14 février et c'est très bien
réalisée c'est-à-dire que d'un seul coup
je sais pas pourquoi découvrez
réalisateur au monde un peu beaucoup
aveuglément j'ai cru que j'allais vivre
une expérience que voilà j'allais mourir
moins bête et je me suis dit ouh blé
qu'est ce qui va se passer qu'est ce qui
va rester de ce truc là et en fait je
tombé amoureux de ce métier la c1 mais
j'aime tout dedans tout du début jusqu'à
la fin il ya un truc que j'aime passer
de montage financier qui est le truc
j'ai pas de problème auditeur ça qu'on
s'est battus souhaite quand même toi
quand tu essayes de monter ton film tu
pars au combat donc le producteur de
belle et sébastien c'est clément me
serait ce donc le mari d'alexandra
sublet c'est lui qui est venu vous
chercher derrière rassurez moi c'est pas
elle sombra sublet qui a qualifié les
dialogues
est non seulement réalisateur mais aussi
acteur tout dancing vous jouez fait un
méchant très réussie peut être vraiment
peur je crois que les gosses font vous
et testez vous parlez de l'ogre des
contes de perrault serait qu'un méchant
faut qu'ils soient méchants l'ambition
dans l'idée de faire ce film c'est de
faire un film d'aventurés qui puisse
réunir un peu tout le monde moi j'ai
trois gamins combien de fois je me suis
tapé des films avec eux où je me dis
[ __ ] qu'est ce que c'est ennuyeux pour
nous quoi et j'avais besoin que les
héros soient confrontés nos à une image
du mal est fait vraiment raser la tête
tout vous c'est une période de chauffe
non je banon je me rasais pour pas
perdre de temps bah ouais et le fait que
tu aies soit dans le sud et dans la vie
c'est aller des neiges oui ça va et ça
m'a aidé
même plus d'une fois
on regarde à 15 ans m
bastien sébastien on avait dit pas dans
la chambre c'est pas du tout comment ils
sont arrivés
new l'autre
sébastien qu'est ce que tu fais tu vas
être en retard à l'école
le chalet de césar connaissent peut vous
emmener je voulais vous avez déjà
regardé sur cette profession dans son
regard avec le vide et la mort elle
savait plus de quatre ans que je cherche
partout machine à cash tube rehab où se
tient demain
michel soit personnes issues ce qu'ils
aiment raccompagner chez eux aussi
[Musique]
je suis trop bien je trouve
ne pas se laisser faire on va aller les
chercher
basket ball in il pense qu on jamais à
nous chercher là bas
six machines a disparu je te jure vous
allez finir dans le ravin
[Musique]
je promets de protéger
profite bien de tokyo
et
[Musique]
l'épave où bella sera jamais à vous
paris voit la belle et sébastien en
sable le casque en publié
[Musique]
oui c'est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà
que j'ai me
c'est la chanson de belle sebastian
oui alors vous n'avez pas peur de la
malédiction des trois parce que les
bronzés 3 taxi trois campings 3 le
parrain iii je crois que c'est assez
naïf
marche mais il a joué dans brise 3 qui
était moyen vrai mais à la lecture du
scénario ça m'a éclaté j'ai vu du jack
london et tout ça paye tout alger pas
penser à un 3 1 4 1 12 en vrai c'est mon
film donc même si si malheureusement il
ya une malédiction sur les 3 franchement
je l'assumé
c'est très gentil mais alors la dernière
question aymeric caron aimerait savoir
si le chien à toucher le même salaire
que vous dans le film je pense qu'ils
sont pas mal payés ah ouais ouais mais
je n'aime pas des j'ai pas eue ah bah
oui parce que un club avec des billets
voilà
je retrouve sur terre
au
soir
mais ce corps et âme
[Musique]
bonsoir les terriens du samu sommes de
retour sur terre toujours en compagnie
de christine bravo
cognac d'aymeric caron de paul taylor
est violent ma vie
quand bien même si on passe un autre
hôtel ou de la semaine
m
les gens
cécile maman bonsoir
alors c'est génial de s'appeler bravo
parce que toute votre vie vous avez cru
qu'on vous féliciter pour le travail
quand on vous disait christine bravo
pour ce que j'ai fait un truc bien vous
êtes quand même la seule animatrice
avoir réussi à tenir 30 ans à la
division de moins en moins sans coucher
on n'a pas beaucoup proposé
alors ça fait 30 ans que le
téléspectateur vous voit vous marrer à
la télévision voilà vous marrer c'est
parce que vous êtes vraiment entouré de
gens qui sont drôles tout le temps ou
parce que vous prenez beaucoup de drogue
parce que je me marre la vie me fait
rire à l'époque de concombres reprochait
de trop rires oui comment dans cette
société où quand même les gens sont pas
vraiment tous en bonne santé ont pas
forcément tous beaucoup d'argent comment
peut-on reprocher à quelqu'un de gier de
rien or dans les limites qui ont fait
votre légende christine n'ya
effectivement le rire avec les yeux
plissés comme ça ce qui fait que les
gens sympas la couleur de vos yeux en
fait ça y est on en voit bien et puis
aussi le doigt a le doigt c'est un peu
comme salaire on regarde
bien louis morissette un petit cadeau et
en même temps une expérience voici des
images étonnantes
en collant ses fesses qu'entre son poste
et les pendant l'émission de christine
bravo on peut arriver à se faire mettre
facile une bonne vingtaine de doigt dans
le cul
j'en connais une qui aurait besoin d'un
petit encouragement un petit peu
chaleureuse que peut faire la même chose
devant christine bravo
c'est assez difficile de rester digne
après sache
[Applaudissements]
or le problème qui signe c'est que ces
derniers mois on n'avait plus de
nouvelles de vous j'en retiens pas un
pro de la semaine dans paris match poser
la question qui est sur toutes les
lèvres que devient questions réponses
j'avais quitté les grosses têtes en
novembre 2016 pour aller faire un tour
du monde à cinq mois de tour du monde
vous avez publié les photos sur
instagram alors on voit la thaïlande la
malaisie
l'australie
les philippines
et puis la fin du tour du monde quoi
alors en gros vous êtes partie pourquoi
vous étiez sachiez que l'on rit caisse
et non pas du tout je suis parti parce
que j'en avais marre de droite à paris
en france c'était le mois de novembre il
est froid et gris
parti à claouey et là j'ai dit c'est
génial on s'en va là vous êtes revenu et
là c'est le drame hélas non ça tourne
très bien parce que si vite vous
consacre une soirée hommage à ces
huitièmes chez nous on fait des soirées
hommage aux gens vivant ce qu'est le
corps mais je suis pas une drôle d'idée
une soirée hommage pour christine bravo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça s'appelle la télé de bravo c'est le
vendredi 16 février à 21h le pitch ses
30 ans de carrière les moments les plus
cultes de froufrous aux grosses têtes en
passant par union libre
50 peut regarder ça c'est mon ami
philippe thuillier qui pourrait donc se
décider maintenant mais c'est lui qui a
proposé cette idée est au fond quand je
me suis revue art je suis dit quand même
je suis bien quoi vous vous êtes
retrouvé à whisky soda est magnifique 1
et puis surtout les émissions était
drôle alors il ya donc la télé de bravo
à 21h pendant deux heures et à 23 heures
elle mais la redif c'est du four ou
pierre arditi qui est quand même le 25
décembre 93 c'est pas d'hier mais qui
sait quand même culte quoi j'ai revu
donc des extraits je me dis mais quelle
liberté on avait ouais mais quelle
liberté les gens me disent pourquoi vous
leur faites pas mais qu'on pourrait plus
par son jupon la femme
vous fout
[Musique]
certainement la femme séduit surtout par
son agent qu'il faut
toute une époque mais le dessin moi je
devais raconter ma vie mais c'est vrai
qu'un jour donc première réunion de
rédaction m'a chez le producteur
j'arrive dans le bureau les que des
filles moi j'étais là je me faisais tout
petit toit bon et à un moment elle
commence à parler de l'épisiotomie en
disant tu te souviens chéri on est resté
15 jours avec les pattes écarté devant
un sèche-cheveux et moi j'avoue je
savais pas ce que c'était des pistes
mais tout le monde sait ce que c'est
vous en avez pour moi c'était un autre
monde alors vous dit en parlant des
chroniqueurs de vaud chroniqueuse que
vous aviez un niveau d'exigence absolue
c'est vrai que c'était très bonne
contrairement dites-vous aux pseudo
chroniqueur d'aujourd'hui penser
qu'aujourd'hui on allait les chercher
dans la presse écrite ouais et pierre
qui avait pas une seule personne sur ce
plateau qui ne qui n'étaient pas
spécialisés dans un domaine mais reconnu
dans un demain et d'effitic voilà
formidablement dans ce gouffre où il y
avait l'instit c'était vous la grosse la
vieille la bourgeoise la sérieuse la
jolie moi je voulais mettre la maîtresse
sm mais personne ne peut accepter on
s'entendait vraiment bien pas tout pas
tout tout non tout non tu me disais à
l'époque
tout je te disais non ouais du bois tu
me disais ah ouais ça c'est vrai
j'aurais dit call of duty naquit et plus
resterait ni ça c'est vrai mon deuxième
biscuits
christine maintenant on pouvait le dire
parce qu'à prescription laquelle disait
le plus de mal de mois attend que je les
regarde ces packs au cheddar ou à gauche
non un peu de sel d'user du mal de
personnes ah je pense que c'était moi
parce que côté du mal de moi parce qu'un
jour les divisions comme dirait laurence
cochet qui était une bourge absolue âge
comme dirait laurence cochet la sodomie
relance le couple oui il m'a rappelé aux
gens mais comment j laurence tu me
l'avais dit mais vous avez dit elle et à
rester dans les annales de la télé comme
ça du jour au regard
j'ai tord
j'aime bien épater la galerie trente ans
de bras fait c'est une grenade qui à
n'importe quel moment peut se
dégoupillent 30 ans de folie jamais
c'est une vieille j'ai toujours choc
comme la
finance meeting comptant le sens de
l'humour calme retour sur le parcours de
la plus allumer des animatrices au
lardin vais jouer je déteste perdre un
temps à partir du moment où vous êtes
prêts à faire n'importe quoi vous c'est
qu'il
[Applaudissements]
veut non ces images d'archivés on vois
rigoler en secouant vos cheveux il ya
aussi deux images d archives on vois
rigoler en en ce coin vos cheveux
bon alors christine dans le dossier de
presse de la télé de bravo il ya écrit
la plus incontrôlable des animatrices
est ce que c'est vrai oui c'est une
personnalité c'est pour ça qu'on vous a
ben voilà il ya un moment que je ne
connaissais pas qu'on a retrouvé en
préparant cette émission où là quand
même quoi c'est quelque chose
pendant que les étoiles chantait et ben
nous on avait un petit dessin de
wolinski
je te crois pas
je crois pas
c'est pas possible ça ils ont pas pu
faire un truc pareil on n'a même pas dit
que l'émission continuer
après soir 3 et non mais là il faut
faire un scandale à l'antenne non mais
je veux dire il faut hurler sur un coup
comme ça
non alors là alors là je le prend très
mal et annoncé que tu étais un an et
demi c'est un thème donc soir faille
dans la sécurité partout bp écoute
j'étais dans les temps on était en
avance
festina lisez l'analyse et
[Musique]
la ja mais on sent un apparatchik du
service public donc il arrive mais qu il
dit christine kristin comme ça et toi tu
es là tu en as rennes 1 foot en rien des
tuniques d'abord chantal forfait
[Musique]
cela
alors christine vous pensiez que pour
vous la télévision s'était terminée vous
disiez d'ailleurs il faut que je trouve
une autre façon de gagner malgré change
de vie lorsque vous étiez en birmanie et
la philippe thuillier vous appelez-vous
dit cherry 25 veut faire une cinquième
saison 2 sous les jupons de l'histoire
qui le samedi à 14h20 qu'elle est
meilleure audience de la chaîne je les
chèques avec la loisne c'est vachement
bien
[Rires]
ça y est vous avez dû vous n'avez pas
être obligé de changer de vie parce que
comme vous disiez vous aviez épuisé nos
économies vous avez une retraite dans
votre boulot oh [ __ ] tu sais pas la
meilleure non j'ai demandé ouais combien
j'allais démarrer ou 1000 euros par mois
oh [ __ ] tu as travaillé toute ta vie
monde sous les 1000 euros 1000 euros
1000 euros
requête de mon chat parce que je
cherchais des croquettes demain ils
achètent des croquettes ernest auchart
les gammes le chat non mais 1000 euros
par mois comment vous dire je suis très
bien qu'il ya des gens qui vivent avec
mel euros par mois mais vous n'allez pas
me dire qu'ils vivent bien
et c'est vrai que j'ai été étonné mais
pareil dans nos métiers
quand on a été puisque vous m'avez payer
quand même en cash et le noir pendant
pas mal d'années j'attache par papa
et à prescriptions les gens 92 93 m un
petit contrôle s'impose corps
christine vous avez déclaré moi je suis
célibataire je ne veux pas d'homme à
domicile et je ne couche que le premier
soir oui
bah oui est ce que c'est de vivre avec
un homme voire de vous re marier dans
l'avenir parce que non d'abord j'ai
oublié ce que c'était
l'amour
ouais je sais ce calibre nantes est
conne en matant le lait ces scripts on
ya cru
en moi j'étais crédit
je t'aime dans pas je pense
[Applaudissements]
aux familles
les
[Musique]
piscine vous dites que c'est la
télévision qui vous a voulu blonde en
fait hein c'est eric harris et la télé 1
c'est grâce à la télé ou à cause de la
télé ou ne serais pas étonné qu'on fasse
une interview blonde
[Musique]
que bois la vache
mais revêt alors qu'est ce qu'elles
pouvaient la pêche
de l'eau de l'eau
massif ô combien de couples d'animaux
environ molise at-il emmener sur son
arche combien de couples d'amis ne
s'épanouissent deux couples seulement
deux coupes de chaque arrêt de chaque
d'accord oui oui
c'est noël on
sera prêt
combien de mois dans l'année
possède 28 jours
à tous les mois bravo
votre panier d'un panier avec 5 pommes
vous en prenez 3 combien en avez-vous
atteint
genre prenez trois années où à l'époque
combien en avez-vous j'ai un panier avec
5 pommes ouais vous en prenez 3 combien
en avez-vous j'en ai cinq si j'en prends
tu n'as rien et 3
alors attention là un avion s'écrase à
la frontière franco autrichien de quel
côté du bâton enterrer les morts nana
ratatat un avion s'écrase la frontière
franco autrichienne de quel côté ils
s'écrasent l'avion s'écrase soudan
compter sur la frontière mais de quel
côté soit vers et les mains
ils sont pas enterrés tout seigneur tout
les intérêts d'un côté hublot non parce
que l'enseignant tabulation la conduire
pour nos dix jeunes qu'est-ce qu'on fait
franck autrichienne - y'a pas de
frontières
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et on passe maintenant à notre terrienne
du samedi soir
[Musique]
alors ce soir dans sa hutte est rien
nous sommes très honorés de recevoir le
dernier mythe grec vivant du haut de ses
60 ans de carrière elle comptabilise à
elle seule 130 4 albums
1600 chanson 300 millions de disques
vendus et 300 disques d'or elle a été
députée au parlement européen
elle est ambassadrice de l'unicef et
elle parle six langues voilà mais on la
connaît
surtout pour ses lunettes ses nana
mouskouri
alors liona mouskouri vous êtes né le 13
octobre 1934 à la canée en crète votre
père konstantinos c'était
projectionniste dans un cinéma et votre
mère ali qui était ouvreuse vit une
grande soeur qui s'appelle eugénie alors
votre père adoré jouer aux cartes
étaient fous de ça et le jour de votre
naissance il était tellement absorbé par
son jeu de cartes qu'il a oublié de
prévenir la sage femme ce qui fait que
votre mère a accouché tout seul c'est
déjà un début
exceptionnel
alors vous avez trois ans quand votre
famille s'installe à athènes et puis
c'est la guerre la grèce est occupée par
l'allemagne nazie vous avez sept ans
quand votre père part combattre dans la
résistance vous n'avez rien à manger
j'étais avec votre mère qui se prive
pour nourrir ses deux filles quand
j'avais des pois chiches elle vous
donner tous
partout
les bombardements vous avez vous cacher
dans la cave d'une brasserie et quand
vous sortez il ya du son sur les
trottoirs il ya des gens qui sont
éviscéré qui sont dénombrés et très tôt
donc vous êtes mise en en contact avec
avec la violence
j'avais quatre ans quand j'ai commencé
j'avais 18 ans quand c'est fini
alors c'était un
individu mais vous savez je pense que
dans la vie quand on commence à avoir
poussé tristesse et toutes les cruautés
déjà gel vous cherchez la la paix dans
la vie la paix et aussi l'amour parce
que quand il ya l'amour il ya aussi la
paix autour il ya la compréhension alors
à l'époque vous serez témoin d'une
exécution publique et cette image vous à
hanter longtemps cela fait longtemps que
le cauchemar que quand vous courent
après pour vous pour vous fusillés est
ce que vous le faites encore maintenant
ce que chemin est ce que ça reste très
lent chez vous quand j'ai un cauchemar
de la nuit je vois une petite fille qui
est autour de d'un qi elle essaye n'est
pas tombé dans le puits ce qui est
terrible en grèce c'est qu'après la
guerre mondiale et la guerre civile donc
c'est très compliqué c'est très violent
et pour fuir la guerre vous chantez
alors vous chanter sur la scène du
cinéma ou votre père travail et vous
chanter cette chanson extraordinaire
évidemment robert de rainbow du magicien
d'oz qui est une chanson que voilà pour
vous c'est une façon toujours oui un
petit bout là juste comme ça
[Musique]
oui
les a
[Applaudissements]
alors dit une chose extraordinaire je
voulais vous dire depuis tout à l'heure
mana c'est que ça fait 30 ans que je
fais ce métier c'est la première fois
que j'ai la chance de vous interviewez
j'en suis très content
[Applaudissements]
alors à vos parents vous inscrivent au
conservatoire vous apprenez le piano
mais vous vous révélez une excellente
vocaliste parce que vous avez une
dissymétrie dans les cordes vocales je
vous avais une anomalie physique en fait
kiffer vous pouvez atteindre des notes
très élevées oui mais il faut travailler
alors quand vos parents n'ont plus assez
d'argent pour payer le conservatoire à
leurs deux filles votre soeur eugénie
s'arrête elle dit et pourtant je
chantais bien très très bien j'étais
mieux pour moi j'avais une petite voir
jouer le début elle s'arrête pour
laisser l'argent pour que je puisse
continuer le mois
oh
[Musique]
alors vous débutez nana dans un groupe
de jazz qui s'appelle chuck eidson
équipes u tin s'appellera les athéniens
alors vous chantez à l'époque dans les
restaurants dans des bars à athènes où
passait à la radio
mais le problème c'est que le fait
justement de chanter dans des bars dans
les restaurants il passe à la radio vous
interdit de passer l'examen de fin
d'année du conservatoire on vous
l'interdît ce qui fait que vos rêves
d'opéra s'écroule voilà c'est ce qui
vous a condamné à la chanson en fait
alors à la fin des années 50 vous
chantez dans un club qui s'appelle zaki
et le compositeur manos hadjidakis vous
repère et vous présente au milieu
artistique atteignant vous faites votre
rentrée quand même dans un milieu un
petit peu plus
sophistiqué et c'est comme ça que vous
rencontrez mélina mercouri actrice et
chanteuse reconnue épouse du cinéaste
jules dassin le père de joe dassin voilà
là vous sortez un premier 45 tours en
1959 qui s'appelle cap ou y pari et
agapit mou
brumelot
ici la voix ouais cette intention est
rien yoanna à 60 ans de carrière là vous
n'êtes même pas à la moitié
en 1960 vous contribuez à l'écriture des
enfants du pire est pour mélina mercouri
la chanson deviendra la chanson du film
jamais le dimanche gros succès et puis
après une victoire dans un radio crochet
vous devenez une vedette dans toute la
grèce aura vous quittez votre groupe les
athéniens pour évoluer tout seul et vous
avez chanté devant des gens comme
aristote onassis mais aussi john
fitzgerald kennedy juan carlos le roi
d'espagne
en 1960 vous vous installer à paris oui
invité par monsieur agents et j'insiste
à les dissuadant qui dirigeait les
disques phillips et les cannois donc
s'installer à paris on regarde
[Musique]
oh
je
chan
ça vaut
oh
il donne des ressacs homme donne une
rose et tout y avait des bonnes manières
dans le show business à l'époque oui et
surtout qu'il y avait le disque roses
blanches et à corfou et en même temps
alors là vous produisez en première
partie de gens comme brassens brel
bécaud à l'olympia des gens que vous
respectez effectivement énormément vous
êtes trà vinh leur première partie et là
on vous demande d'enlever vos lunettes
qui vous a demandé monsieur ans le
premier c'était mieux avant il y avait
les lunettes et mon nom me dit tu veux
pas taper
nana si je chantais des chansons
sérieuses et les lunettes aussi mais les
lyonnais tu savais tout myope toute ma
vie mais maintenant je suis plus vite
aussi ça mais il ya d'autres choses mais
c'était comme une protection pour moi
c'est devenu votre geek quoi nana
mouskouri l'une a déjà bien fait de pas
arrêter parce que voilà maintenant je
suis heureuse je vois tout le monde l'a
dit lunettes j'avais tellement serré
polnareff
alors c'est là que vous commencez
enregistrée dans toutes les langues
parce qu'une de vos grandes
particularités c'est effectivement ou
chanter dans toutes les langues et est
en français évidemment une chanson qui
s'appelle si tu m'aimes
[Musique]
eu le temps
bonjour
[Musique]
cette chanson et sans lumière et la
chanson du film le flanc farrow et
vittorio gassman en 1962 vous débarquez
à new york quincy jones borderie quincy
jones produit votre premier album en
anglais qui s'appelle the girl from luis
things et il faudra attendre 1965 pour
que vous séduisent y est le public
populaire français avec l'enfant du
tambour ohlala fanfare aux terminaux
[Musique]
alors l'enfant du tambour on a été élevé
avec ça
les enseignements ont été levés mais
c'est tout un programme dont les écoles
ah oui l'enfant descendre ici les bois
oui chérie je ne peux pas vous
contrarier mais il ne s'agit pas de
l'enfant du tambour les tambours ne font
pas d'enfant c'est l'enfant au tambour
alors
1975 avait déjà trente cinq disques d'or
et deux ans plus tard doit rester trois
semaines l affiche de un piia salle
olympia c'est votre endroit culte pas
j'étais en tournée en ce moment là et un
jour mais chocolaterie qui m'appelle il
me dit j'ai besoin des nanas pour
qu'elle passe à l'olympia parce que
gilbert bécaud est malade alors
je lui ai dit mais vous savez je suis en
tournée et puis j'attends un bébé et
puis le 10 mai normalement ce programme
les gens ils font pitié avec les
lunettes et le ventre ça va être bien
mais c'est pas seulement ça il m'a dit
j'ai rien trouvé au tour de marc un
artiste libre pour chanter alors vous
êtes la seule qui peut être disponible
le bulma d'octobre et et voilà et je ne
crois pas évidemment je crois pas du
tout à vous vous mais pour faire mon
travail et bien il ya un nouveau artiste
extraordinaire comique qui était jacques
martin elle m'a dit je vais le prendre
comme américaine il va remplir même les
impôts d'un essai ce qui s'est passé
alors on commence à rentrer en grève
donc c'est la fin des colonels vous
retrouvé votre pays donc retrouvé lui la
liberté et vous chantez ensuite le
générique de la fameuse série de france
2 fois d'antenne 2 à l'époque l'amour en
héritage
le monde
[Musique]
matin
bp
à
[Musique]
lee
jenny
ce qui est bien c'est vous connaissez
toutes les paroles à
elle que quelle que soit la chanson
on va voir si c'est le même cas avec le
le tube qui vient on regarde
[Musique]
deschamps tout bizarre
on se
[Musique]
il marche en tête
je
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qui s'est passé vous aider
j'ai besoin d'argent
bien sûr je respecte la forme et je suis
pas quelqu'un qui fais les choses pas
pour l'argent et alors mais c'est vrai
qu'elle là il y avait des choses il
était bien payé et en plus c'était
c'était juste jacquin vous connaissez je
serai car il faudra voir louis et
j'étais un très grand ami à moi et puis
il m'a dit écoute et que j'ai fait
quelque chose si tu veux on va les faire
ensemble est propre oui ce thème
comprend pourquoi
bien désinfecter les problèmes cités que
j'avais tellement honte et que j'ai dit
la seule chose que je peux faire c'est
de donner un avis et comme j'ai
travaillé par sida avec unicef j'ai mis
l'argent sur lui c'est oui on va voir
vous avez nana mouskouri
extrêmement bon coeur parce que quand
vous êtes élu député européen
après vous arrêter vous aidera une
retraite de député européen et cette
retraite vous l'avez donné à la grèce
pour rembourser la dette grecque
aujourd'hui on vous sortez votre nouvel
album qui s'appelle ferait beihang donc
vous serez à pleyel le 8 mars
jean du samedi soir
[Applaudissements]
je ris
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in
a l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu